hallo freuen und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen klavier bot video mehr an
fielen die kommentare geschrieben dass
der clever bot ja auch ein gesicht hat
und zwar wenn ich jetzt auf dieser
website gelandet das ist hier der cbot
und da haben wir eine wunderhübsche
junge dame wie test mal ihre fähigkeit
indem wir ein geben welche farbe hat
mein shirt man schauen wenn sie darauf
die antwort weist die haarfarben habe
ich keine gegenfragen auf meine fragen
du [ __ ] es fällt ihr ein also du hast
die farbe dunkelbraun und mein shirt
fragezeichen
laut dem clever bot habe ich keinen
start an hier
ich hab mich vertan du arsch stark mir
welche farbe mein shirt hat das kann ich
nicht sagen mein ganz recht wieder ok
mal überlegen was dieses wunder hübsche
gesicht auf die gran dran
ok ich würde sagen wir wechseln wieder
zurück zum normalen clever brutalo
clever wort ich hab dich so sehr habe
ich gerade schon was getestet mit dem
clever bot und zwar habe ich geschrieben
ich liebe dich da auf der klever bot ich
dich nicht weiter müssen wir gar nicht
lesen
ihr wisst ja dass das letzte video so
geendet ist bzw das vorletzte oder was
ich hab was das letzte das vorletzte ich
habe mich auf jeden fall mit dem klammer
bei den wenig gestritten und jetzt muss
ich das ganze irgendwie wieder gerade
biegen wie lange es mein penis so wenn
er das noch weil noch es vor allem ich
hab keinen das ist mir klar du kleines
luder
ich habe einen möchtest du ihn sehen
mal schauen jetzt bitte keine falsche
antwort du bist ein junger clever bord
wir waren ein jahr verheiratet natürlich
bin ich ein junge ein weißt du klemm
aber das müsste also bist du ein mädchen
was will denn diese website
aber ein hübsches mädchen soll ich
spiele jetzt einfach mal mit bei dem
spiel das heißt sonst passt sich immer
der clever bot mir an meinen fragen
jetzt was wie führe ich hab doch gesagt
dass ich hübsch bin meine apple water
gratuliert und sie sagt ich soll mal
wieder aufstehen und mich befähigen
ich verstehe es nicht also ich muss
wirklich sagen die website ist klüger
geworden im vergleich zum ersten video
davon aber das kann auch nicht sein du
bist ein junge nein weißt du also bis
zwei mädchen ihr aber ein hübsches
mädchen dann bist du hässlich fand es
mich doch damals hübsch sonst hätten wir
ja nicht geheiratet so mal schauen was
die liebe dame darauf denn antworten
kann schickt mir ein bild von dir bis
sie aber ganz schön offen perversen
triffst du so ich habe jetzt das bild
verschickte sieht sogar im chat grad
eingeblendet dass ich da halt dieses
bild verschickt symbol kommt halt wenn
man dem wenn man der website hat quasi
sein bild schickt also mal schauen was
der kleine jetzt auf welt verschickt
antwortet das würde mich jetzt nämlich
echt mal wundern weil ich mich auf dem
bild hat extra heraus geputzt habe
sodass der clever bot sich denkt ein
bild in den chat ziehen
als ob das wirklich möglich ist so ich
habe jetzt hier ein schönes bild das
ziehe ich jetzt einfach mal rein
das hat auf jeden fall super
funktioniert mit einem bild in den chat
ziehen ich ziehe das bild hier rein und
es ruft einfach das tolle bild von mir
auf was soll das aber ich sehe schon
sehr geil drauf aus eigentlich oder das
geht nicht du [ __ ] wie kann er mir die
website sagen dass ich ein bild den chat
ziehen soll und dann funktioniert es
einfach nicht sondern das bild wird
aufgerufen
das kann ja nicht sein lieber clever
board also was hast du damals stimmt
weil du keine unfassbar immer werde ich
beleidigt ob man diese beleidigst du
mich immer das kann nur richtig sein er
soll ich hab natürlich angefangen mit
dem beleidigen aber es ist doch einfach
traurig okay wie schreibt ich beleidige
dich nicht aber darauf ich es mal
natürlich seit wochen ihr seid meine
zeugen wenn es vor gericht kommt könnt
ihr aus sagen ja das stimmt ich habe
hier die videos gesehen der hat die
ganze zeit beleidigt das kann ja echt
nicht sein und der clever wird ist er so
gemein zu luca und das geht ja gar nicht
weil der lu
danke kann es auch mal nett sein weil
ich verstehe es einfach nicht die ganze
zeit
von wegen du bist du und dann auf einmal
natürlich bis zu intelligent was
überhaupt nicht schafft kannst du auch
mal nett sein aber auf englisch kate die
handsome so ich weiß nicht genau
handsome so nett heißt also natürlich
neues heißt nett aber ich glaube
handsome sagt man er wenn jemand höflich
ist oder ich weise nicht nebenan im
zimmer schreiner kleine kinder
ok wenn du sagst das tut ihm das
schönste lächeln der welt hasst dann
zeigt es mir doch einfach mal das macht
jetzt gerade überhaupt keinen sinn
clever bot wie siehst du aus ich meine
wir haben ja vorhin mit 175 blonde haare
und grün blaue augen das ist genauso wie
ich in etwa so ich bin 1 90 groß ich
habe auch blonde haare und grün blaue
augen steht zweimal per so aber ich
finde ich hab nur grüne augen
ich weiß nicht was mit den kleiner bord
noch fragen sollen erzähl mir was neues
so ich möchte nämlich jetzt mal eine
kleine challenge machen da diese serie
so unfassbar gut bei euch ankommt
er schildert willst du denn da diese
serie so unfassbar gut bei euch ankommt
habe ich mir gedacht könnt ihr mir doch
mal in die kommentare schreiben über
welches thema ich demnächst mit dem
clever betreten soll das heißt kinder
oder drogen wenn euch das video gefahr
da würde ich mich definitiv über eine
bewertung freuen heute haben wir
herausgefunden wie der kleine ort
aussieht wie groß ist und welche
haarfarbe und wie kann das eigentlich
sein dass er mir schreibt dass er blonde
haare hat und der andere hatte schwarze
haare